Nuestra historia es sobre
una chica llamada Iris.
Iris es muy sensible.
Tanto que está
siempre en lágrimas.
Llora cuando está triste,
cuando está feliz,
e incluso cuando algo
simplemente la conmueve.
Tiene glándulas lagrimales especiales
para hacer nuevas lágrimas
y tubos especiales,
llamados puntos lacrimales,
para drenar las viejas.
Y llora tanto que
por ella pasan
300 ml de lágrimas por día,
¡114 litros al año!
De hecho, si te fijas bien,
verás que está llorando
un poco todo el tiempo.
Las lágrimas basales que
Iris produce constantemente
forman una cubierta
delgada de tres capas
que cubre y mantiene lejos
la suciedad y los desechos.
Justo al lado de Iris
está la capa mucosa,
que mantiene
todo sujeto a ella.
Encima está la capa acuosa,
que mantiene hidratada a Iris,
repele las bacterias invasoras,
y protege su piel,
la córnea, de los daños.
Y, finalmente,
está la capa de lípidos,
una película aceitosa externa
que mantiene la superficie lisa
para que Iris pueda
ver a través de ella,
e impide la evaporación
de las otras capas.
Normalmente, Iris pasa su día
sin darse cuenta realmente
de las lágrimas basales
haciendo sus cosas.
Este es la idea.
Pero un día, conoce a
una chica llamada Cebolla.
Iris queda
inmediatamente prendida.
Cebolla se veía preciosa con
su chaqueta púrpura brillante,
y olía genial.
Así que Iris invita a Cebolla
a su casa para la cena,
pero cuando entra y se
quita su chaqueta,
sucede algo terrible.
Verás, cuando Cebolla
se quita la chaqueta,
ocurre una reacción química,
los sulfóxidos que la hacen
oler genial, se convierten
en ácido sulfénico,
que luego se convierte en una sustancia
desagradable con un nombre largo:
syn-propanotial-S-óxido.
El gas le arde a Iris,
y repentinamente,
no puede evitarlo,
comienza a llorar
descontroladamente.
Estas lágrimas reflejas son
diferentes de las lágrimas basales
a las que Iris
está acostumbrada.
Porque están diseñadas
para eliminar las sustancias
nocivas, o las partículas,
son liberadas en
cantidades mucho mayores
y su capa acuosa
contiene más anticuerpos
para detener cualquier microorganismo
que pueda estar intentando entrar, también.
Iris y Cebolla están devastadas.
Saben que no pueden
seguir su relación
si Iris se va
a herir y llorar
cada vez que Cebolla
se quita su chaqueta.
Entonces, deciden romper.
Tan pronto Cebolla
sale por la puerta,
Iris deja de llorar.
E inmediatamente
comienza otra vez.
Solo que ahora no está
llorando lágrimas reflejas
sino lágrimas emocionales.
Cuando alguien está demasiado
triste o demasiado feliz,
siente como una
pérdida de control,
que puede ser peligrosa.
Así, las lágrimas
emocionales son enviadas
para estabilizar
el estado de ánimo
tan pronto como sea posible,
junto con otras reacciones físicas,
como un mayor ritmo cardíaco
y la respiración más lenta.
Pero los científicos
aún no están seguros
exactamente cómo o por qué son
útiles las lágrimas por sí mismas.
Pueden ser un
mecanismo social
para lograr simpatía
o mostrar sumisión.
Pero algunos estudios
han encontrado también
que las lágrimas emocionales
contienen niveles más altos
de hormonas de estrés,
como la ACTH y la encefalina,
una endorfina y analgésico natural.
En este caso, las lágrimas emocionales
son también para calmar directamente a Iris,
así como para expresar su
estado emocional a los demás.
Lástima que las cosas no
funcionaran con Cebolla, Iris,
pero no te preocupes.
Mientras tengas
las tres clases de lágrimas
funcionando para mantenerte
equilibrada y sana,
mejorará.
Ya verás.